[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos hi guys as you can see i'm super
ecstatic that is hawking that is my
first custom statute and with getting a
custom statue
there's a lot that goes into it it's a
lot of patience it's a lot of trust on
the person that you get in stature from
and probably on your end as well because
these pieces are commissioned I believe
only thirty was made in the world and I
have number 30 I'm absolutely happy to
share this with you I know a lot of you
guys are saying like why hawkman um
I found this custom sculpture through a
friend and I saw the pieces that he had
and I'm going for this giant excellent
statue which will probably have lost
that statue if you can believe myself
this is the biggest statue that I have
this is the largest statue that I
haven't always got you rather have this
statute is truly epic this is what when
I say an epic statue this is a Holy
Grail Holy Grail as a piece that you go
to somebody's collection not too many
people have it and everybody's gonna
want it the level of detail on this
character on this stand on the statue
it's unprecedented the weight of it is
enormous I believe it comes in probably
I like 60 pounds
um the wings is made out of real wood as
you can see by the level of detail and
the pictures because there will be a ton
of pictures for this one I'm going to
make sure if you stick around and watch
the video you will see a ton of pictures
for this one now I know you're probably
saying you know why Hulk man um I looked
at his pieces and he had an x-men vs.
The Sentinel and I was a large piece as
well and the price of the piece was I
believe probably like $2,000
and in yoga get the down payment they
have to send it you have to trust that
this person's gonna take this payment
and we're gonna deliver this piece all
right
usually the pieces go into production
and it takes a while so I saw hawkman
and I was like all the level of detail
is so incredible I need really be honest
with you sighs and I was like whatever
you know that space down here I believe
I have a shelf that has space for it or
I have open tape before business this
has to be a central mystery there's no
way around other than it being a center
piece for you okay so I ordered it and
it came in a came from China direct from
the sculptor and the artist who painted
it a lot of times guys don't want you to
go into that information this is from
isin art you can follow them on
Instagram and you can look at it pieces
there once I received the piece I didn't
open it right away and because I knew I
was gonna do this show
and then during the show I knew that
this was going to be my great white will
this was going to be my piece that once
I got enough people that was gonna watch
the channel they make him Cetus and I'm
I had I sat on it for probably six
months and I am so happy to put this
statue up um once I received a statue
and I looked at other pieces that he had
coming and he has the doctor doing
coming in and you know I preordered to
dr. guma send them the money because I
can shot with him in confidence
um so when the statue came on boxes
yesterday I had a minor minor breakage -
it's on the foot I will show the picture
right right there um yeah
hurt my heart but you know
who blew it up one little piece to it
minor but to make it to me all the way
from and I honestly believe customs
broken I don't believe that it was a
ship because it is packed impeccably but
if you see the scene I don't know if
those are zombies fighting it looks like
zombies that he was fighting and he's
tearing through them the body's part is
all over the place the resin looks
incredible the paint application is
insane the level of detail on this
character beats any detail from any high
retail place that I've purchased I
highly recommend eyes on I highly do the
name is gonna be in a description it's
nothing this this I'm speechless I'm
absolutely 100% speechless if you look
at that the head on the ax right here
look at that
that level of detail is unheard of and
the axe is as heavy as a real axe all
right
despite the mace that's in the base the
wings the character is solid comes with
to switch out heads
I like this head I don't like the other
one that look like a fish you can see it
right there it looks like a fish I don't
like that once you tough um but this is
my holding room this is my centerpiece
this is the absolute apex among other
statues will be judged
this is Kos Mike final subscribe and
also go to Lourdes a game and got net
where you can see other opinion pieces
new stuff that's coming up for the
PlayStation 5 also the new Xbox system
and you can listen to other podcasts
that are there that are we link to where
iron Lords podcast is there and also the
last word with kognito and Yvonne says
you in Tallulah shooters trust me you
don't want to miss the last word but
this is Kos and guys this is my heart
going out to you please stick around to
listen and watch the videos also if
you're part of our YouTube our Twitter
and our Instagram I mean and our
Facebook sorry you can also see the
promo videos that I put up for the
statue which is different you will hear
the 1967 TV show for Hawkman man I am so
proud and happy to have this statue
shout-out to eyes art where they do the
best work
statue is absolutely worth every last
penny thank you see you next week stick
around and listen to me
[Music]